i'm tim ferriss author entrepreneur
angel investor and now tv host
i've spent my entire adult life asking
questions then scouring the globe to
find the answers
on this show i'll share the secrets of
pioneers who have faced their own fears
we'll dig into the hard times big
mistakes tough decisions and how they
got through it all
the goal isn't to be fearless the goal
is to learn to fear less
[Music]
welcome to fearless i'm your host tim
ferriss and on this very stage we'll be
deconstructing world-class performers of
all different types to uncover the
specific tactics they've used to
overcome doubt tackle their hardest
decisions and ultimately succeed on
their own terms so imagine yourself
standing 127 thousand feet above the
earth trying to set the free fall world
record or stepping onto the field for
the super bowl or perhaps attempting to
take gold at the olympics
if you were nervous or if you had to
prepare for that who would you turn to
who would you ask for help in less than
a decade my guest has built a very
impressive client roster that includes
olympic gold medalists like carrie walsh
jennings teams like the seattle seahawks
and the u.s armed forces please welcome
to the stage dr michael gervais
[Applause]
[Music]
the step has gotten me you guys ready
for a show
all right uh we are going to begin with
a video so let's roll that
128 000 feet above the ground felix
baumgardner stood at the edge of space
preparing to do what none had done
before
and then when the moment was right he
took a step
leaving the capsule behind and beginning
his 24 mile fall to earth
along the way baumgartner reached a
speed of 833 miles per hour becoming the
first skydiver to break the sound
barrier
after falling four and a half minutes
baumgartner deployed his chute and
floated to the earth in the desert of
new mexico
that was not me that was not him
that was me no that wasn't me either
yeah that was felix baumgartner who
jumped out of space from 130 000 feet
from the stratosphere on the red bull
stratos program what was that like
helping him through a fear that would
allow him to go to a place that no other
humans been
and when he jumped to jump
from 130 127 000 feet to jump and
possibly go through a double sonic boom
where some of the brightest minds were
not sure
if his
limbs would make it through that sonic
boom what was his primary fear wow he
could
die well
yeah what kind of this guy calls himself
a professional
uh
but okay
good answer uh
what what did the work look like
so he needed to be in a spacesuit for x
number of hours five to six hours and um
he became claustrophobic he could no
longer be in the suit
for i think at that time it was like 30
minutes and so he had to rip off the
helmet and and get out of it
and so they scrub they were scrubbing
the project it was done because if the
person can't be in there for 30 minutes
then it's not going to work period
and then so they asked me to come in and
see if i could help him move through
that experience
and it is possible to extinguish fear it
is dangerous
and
many people don't make it through it
and he wanted it and he wanted it
with
all of his faculty about himself and he
really was going to do the work because
it mattered more for him to go for it
and die
than to play it safe and never
experience its potential
and what did what does extinguishing
phobia look like i knew you'd want to
talk more about it yeah oh yeah
so how do you extinguish phobia
there's good science there's two main
kind of ways that
as approaches
systematic desensitization and flooding
and so it is possible to extinguish you
know a fear response to something that
you have and so how do you do it um
there's this i don't know how much in
the weeds you want to get with this
yeah okay so
flooding as a concept is that if
somebody has a fear response to whatever
it is
that um you and that person agree that
you're going to put them in that
environment and not let them leave
until they extinguish the fear until
they have a new hard a new wiring of the
response to the stimulus once that
flooding of emotion takes place
and the circuitry is going haywire and
they're not reinforcing the response by
exiting you force them to stay in that
environment hook or crook
that um a new pattern emerges and so
that's the essence of it that's pretty
radical
now it's like the indiana jones into the
pit of snake's approach yeah that's
exactly right now maybe he's cured but
so what happens for all of us in
fear-based responses so say it's a mouse
or whatever it might be or public
speaking or whatever it is is that mouse
comes across the the countertop and
tension and then exit
so then thinking over time and if that
happens to get attention and then exit
and then over time just thinking about a
rat or a mouse on a countertop
and you would just want to get away so
there's that looping behavior of tension
and exit
and so
it's possible to re-circuit it but it
takes time and flooding the counterpart
to flooding is systematic
desensitization just like building up a
tan
yeah yeah you can do it two ways you can
do it uh in reality and you can do it in
imagination
and so there's a set of protocols that
you would walk somebody through
backfill them with
some strategies on arousal control and
thought management
so arousal control is breathing
techniques or whatever and then thought
management is increasing awareness of
one's thoughts so you can guide and
adjust and play with your thoughts maybe
at one point and so you backfill the
mental skills those are mental skills
for them and then walk them through an
experience where they'll list the
triggers of the fear that they're
walking into from zero to 100 or zero to
ten
and then you systematically put them
into those environments either in
imagination or in reality i did both but
they can't leave stage three
until they've brought their heart rate
down to
rewire the fear response so that's the
long the really long answer to it so
you've worked with some of the highest
profile most successful athletes on the
planet but it didn't start there
where did you grow up
my roots are in a small town in called
warrenton virginia were you a happy kid
would you say yeah i didn't know any
better i was like it felt like
being out in the in the abundance of
nature that i didn't have worries or
concerns and i was just a kid trying to
sort out how to be a kid
and then uh which is a great gift like
parents like that's a really i feel like
that was an incredible gift that they
gave me
so then
dad started working into some corporate
worlds and then
uh punched over to california when i was
young it was fourth grade
so i had to figure out how to adjust
from the farm to northern california and
now i'm straight in the city i i was
like i was a hillbilly i just was trying
to figure out
how to fit in you know and
the fitting in is such a strong human
need
and i do remember though well enough
that i couldn't come home to my parents
and talk to them about being picked on i
mean and then finally i came home
and so i said dad
a kid after school said he's going to
chew me out i said what is that
and so chews you out it was like hey
we're going to fight yeah now a
hillbilly doesn't know what that is so
so choose you out so the next day my
dad's my dad my mom and my grandmother
were in our living room and they're
showing me how to fight as a president
so it was fantastic and so my dad knew
how to fight what was grandma's move
great okay so grandma
i'm glad you picked up grandma was on
point so grandma she says um it was like
the last finishing touches she says make
sure and check if they have a ring
okay not a bad idea and she says cover
yourself
cover yourself
and i looked at like what do you mean
she says well have one hand to hit him
and one hand to protect yourself
good advice for a lot of things okay
grandma yeah so yeah so that was that
was the family environment how'd the
fight go what happened yeah so so here i
am i'm getting ready to go and you know
i'm thinking like do i go this way do i
what do i do
and i remember like okay it's going i
looked it for the ring no ring i'm okay
he we're dancing like we're gonna do
something and i see my mom and my
grandmother driving
and they parked right there and i was
like okay well it's not gonna be that
bad and then i started to get
embarrassed like my mom is here right
you know and so i think she starts
starting to scuffle and then the car
drove off and she kind of saw that it
was going to be okay it wasn't like
we're not going to shank each other or
something so
and so um yeah that was my that was my
welcome to kelly wait a second so did
you guys get in get into it oh yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah how did it and afterwards
what was what was the end result so i
think when 10 year olds fight like you
try to throw some punches this is what i
remember i tried to throw some punches
he tried to throw some punches we ended
up wrestling it went to the ground all
the other kids split it up and then i
got up and i was like am i cool now and
so
and uh and it was fine it worked out
just fine
what was your high school experience
like high school i jumped down
to southern california same exact story
same exact story from fourth grade
same exact thing but the guys are a
little bit bigger
fight clubs okay fight club socal there
it is and i just didn't know their way i
didn't know their style yet about how to
be you know in high school i didn't even
know how to be myself
and so there we show up and or i showed
up and i ended up getting in another
fight with this kid
blood was all over the place and i took
off my shirt and i was like dude let's
stop you know he's bleeding out let's
stop
and so i'll never forget that because he
and i uh david hall is his name he and i
became great friends
really great friends he brought me in
showed me how like the surfing culture
works and i served some of the biggest
waves you know with him in high school
so it ended up being a really cool
transition for me so you mentioned not
knowing yourself or how not knowing how
to be yourself oh yeah can you elaborate
on that
yeah so um
i don't know when p i don't know exactly
when people become
the person that they're sorting out to
become
but there is there is a transition that
that does happen for people and for me
i was i was very late in figuring out
who i was
and so i was very very busy early on in
my life up until this point and further
through
the first year of college
where i cared so much so much about what
other people thought of me
i was consumed with it i would and and
so it's now studying it's called
cognitive dissonance where
it's almost nearly impossible to be in
the present moment because part of you
is working on monitoring the way that
you look or you might be perceived by
another person
and it's a really
painful experience to be caught in the
consumption of what another person might
be thinking
you mentioned surfing was that
a small
moderate big piece of your life when the
biggest
how did it fit in yeah in
so younger younger years
i had a reaction to being coached
and i didn't like the way it felt for
another human to tell me
yes or no or give me approval because i
was already so sensitive to it it's like
my position in surfing no not in surfing
that was in stick uh traditional stick
and ball sports
so i moved away from that because my cup
was already full
and to have another adult you know coach
me or critique me in front of peers was
just it was just too much
and i think that's the case for a lot of
kids sure i don't think i was unique in
that i was an anxious
uh overly aggressive through
compensation kid you know so i came from
an anxious place
did that ever
affect your surfing yeah the anxiousness
that i felt while surfing
actually kept me from pursuing it
competitively
and so the idea the thing i cared most
about and i had this other part of me
that was just crippled by being consumed
about what others were thinking that i
couldn't feel my feet i couldn't feel my
body i couldn't access
what i knew that i was capable of doing
and so any given day on free and free
surfing
it was fine and i was one of the guys
right
but then as soon as the tent would go up
as soon as the judges showed up as soon
as the the
friends and family showed up all of a
sudden my brain was overloaded with what
could go wrong because that's that is
the essence of what anxiety is a
a consumption of what could go wrong and
you couldn't get there because you had
this dominating anxiety anxiousness
did you have any inkling of what you
wanted to be when you grew up at that
point i didn't even know the field of
high performance in sports psychology
existed i thought i was going to go to
junior college
surf as much as i possibly could could
because i figured that out in high
school and it would just be a nice
little two-year run you know junior
college
and then i met two men three mentors
three professors that were best friends
dr cuzio dr perkins and dr zenka
and uh they're a theologian
a philosopher and a psychologist
they saw me coming right they saw this
kid that was just bumbling through life
and those three wrapped their arm around
me and showed me how to love and be
fascinated by the invisible
yeah
i love saying your name yeah so
describe for us the
first meeting with any of those three i
think it was the philosophy class dr
zenko or dr perkins and i showed up into
his class and i was like
well who who are these people you know
aristotle and plato and seneca and like
who are these people like that's some
real stuff they offered me to take the
special class like this leadership
invite-only kind of class and they took
they gave us uh tao te ching yeah okay
um
which is a fascinating read if you i'm
sure that you spent some time with it
and they gave us the art of seeing these
two books the art of seeing the art of
seeing like the title i don't know the
book beautiful book yeah both of them
are about the same style very poetic
very deep and they had there was about
15 of us and they said hey listen we're
going to go to the bottom of the grand
canyon that's what this class is we're
going to teach you how to live on your
own for a week
and then
the only rule is that you get these two
books a pencil and a pad of paper and
that's it that you cannot see any other
person for that week
life-changing
wow like brad i i wish everybody could
do something like most amazing class
ever yeah really and so it's just go get
lost literally and go see what you find
and it was hard what did you write about
you know i i i don't know
i don't know i wish i could tell you
what i s what i
wrote but i experienced something that
changed me
well what was the experience describe
the experience to us um being scared
uh figuring out how to face anxiety
and because i'm alone by myself which is
my head my hands and my feet and that's
it and this pad of paper and these rich
texts
and there was nothing else for me to
turn to
it was just you know when you face down
that stuff and i mean really face your
ghosts
and really face
the things that haunt you the most
it changes you
after you came back from that experience
how did your goals
or direction change
yeah i just felt like um
you know there's this gradual switching
on to like there's this thirst and
hunger to try to understand how the
human experience works and it's
complicated
there's no shortcut to the path of
mastery or understanding the complexity
and the beauty of the human experience
it's complicated and so i wrapped up a
bachelor's degree in psychology and i
didn't know anything you don't know
anything with that
master's degree in kinesiology because i
want to understand the body a little bit
more i didn't know anything phd in
psychology with an emphasis in
performance and across the hall was a
tibetan buddhist psychology program so
we had this east west you know i still
didn't know anything
and so i and i'm not saying i know it
now i'm saying that like it's hard to
understand the nuances of how the human
mind body and spirit work
and so that's kind of that was the
beginnings for me of that trajectory
when did you start honing in on or
discovering for that matter sports
psychology or performance psychology so
i had a mentor um
gary de blasio who helped shape my
understanding of myself during those
college years when i graduated from
school i was like i don't know what to
do now and he said well there's this
part-time temporary job
and um
it became an 18-year run
wildly successful using sport and
psychology
to
teach
young men in in los angeles every
saturday night the basic basic most
basic mechanics of how the mind works
it was phenomenal and it was wonderful
and so i what i was doing is i had this
working laboratory the beginnings of a
working laboratory of how to take the
ivory tower stuff and land it to a group
of 100
100 or so kids that really didn't want
to listen to me but wanted to play ball
and that was the president that was that
was the price they had to pay and so so
and so that was the beginnings of kind
of
what would be an example of one of your
uh
most successful or best received of
those talks and i don't expect you to
remember all the details but just to
give an example of how you take
something that could be very complex
and put it into a 15-minute presentation
or something like that what might be a
principle that you would talk about
starting with figuring out who you are
is the largest work you can do as a
human
but when we start there it can
it's so kind of big and heavy to begin
so it begins to seem overwhelming
so i would say like in a perfect world
where people are like i want to do
whatever it takes to be my very best to
have a deep meaningful life and to kick
ass at what i do like i want to i'm
going to do the work then i begin there
and we just go on a journey to figure
out how can you articulate who you are
in 1 to 20 words and the litmus test for
that
is that under
under duress
imagine that we're met in a dark alley
and you and i have done this work
i've heard about your fighting stories i
don't want to be in a dark gallery
i was in fourth grade right and yeah i
didn't know what to do with my hands so
in
imagine wearing a dark alley we've done
the work what happens for most human
beings
is that they'll do the intellectual work
to say this is my philosophy they'll
spend a lot it's a thoughtful time to
shape that in just the right way but
under duress somebody comes behind you
with a knife right and they say hey
listen i'm gutting people that can't say
what they stand for
most people can't get it out so it
begins with the foundation who are you
how do you make decisions is what a
philosophy is
what would be an example
maybe do you have one yourself but it
could be hypothetical an example of the
the one to twenty word answer if you
think about some of the if you think
globally about the most influential
people in the world they're political
leaders and spiritual leaders that's who
shapes our global culture so what is
jesus's philosophy
what is buddha's philosophy what would
jesus be love
what would buddhists be loving kindness
all people suffer have compassion
so why do we know what was martin luther
king jr's philosophy
dr king was about equality we know it
because he was clear about what it was
he said it he walked about it he talked
about it and when he went in a room it
was real and that's what he talked about
all and did as a life effort there's no
confusion so
mine is
every day is a opportunity for a living
masterpiece
and that's the way i orientate
my life every day and i'm training those
important words inside of it every day
and so i see this is a gift that you've
given me to be able to share the things
that i think about a lot so thank you
this is fun for me so it's a gift to me
as well i really appreciate it
and i do do you have a philosophy
i would say uh first thing comes to mind
is hope for the best prepare for the
worst i mean is that the thing that that
that makes your heart thump a little bit
and that's how you make decisions
you push it through that's how i make a
lot of decisions say it again
hope for the best prepare for the worst
hope for the best prepare for the worst
and is there that's not what drives
that's more of a sort of an operating
system
rule like a logical rule that i use for
preparation definitely but it wouldn't
be the thing that drives me
yeah so i think when you get that thing
right
that's it and so i'll tell you a quick
little litmus test for it is that if
there's a word or part of that sentence
where your heart thumps just a little
bit it's like
there's a skipping of a beat there's a
we can describe why that takes place
that's when you know you're on to
something
when it's like that's it i just
god that's big i hope i can do that i
don't know if you the person across me
can understand it but it's that type of
beautiful
work to articulate the thing that is
pure about you and and that it's a
decision making framework of how you
push everything that you do why you buy
your car or your clothes or why you're
here
you know so that's what it's about what
was your first paid gig with an athlete
he was a professional hockey player and
he was on the minor leagues and he had
all this potential now the word
potential can be a crippler
because you get performance anxiety
about the expectations yeah
so when we have our little kids parents
as we have our kids and we say you have
great potential we have to be thoughtful
about how we share that word with them
because it can create expectations that
there's more which is great but the idea
that you're not reaching your potential
is right on the other am i reaching my
potential it's right on the other side
of it and so we did some great work we
worked through some stuff and then he
said i got my shot
i said oh boy i hope i hope this thing
works because at that point i don't i
didn't really know what i was doing yeah
but i was asking questions and i was
present with them and i was you know
and so um
he got a shot and he crushed it and he
did great and you know so we hugged it
out afterwards it was one of those you
know beautiful moments that you just you
think about like the celebration of
the strong man or woman you know who was
nervous and scared figuring it out it
was it was wonderful
what are some of the most
fascinating pre-performance routines or
effective that you've seen okay
so as a strategy to find one's ideal
competitive mindset right there there's
some good research in science around
um having a routine to go through like
almost like a checklist to turn on or
activate that mindset
the not great examples are superstitions
that's not what we're talking about like
if i hop over the line or i do something
if i wear my dirty socks i'm going to be
successful that's awful right that it's
like that
there's a lot of people are upset with
me because like that's part of like the
entire baseball tradition right it's
it's a it's archaic it's bad science
it's not good it creates a fragile
mindset because what happens if your
dirty sock is no longer there right
as we have problems so
so it's not that what it is is having
let's say one two or three things let's
make it super simple that that are
triggers for you to think a certain way
for you to adjust your body posture that
is in alignment with your ideal
competitive mindset and so take it from
the rhetoric into something more applied
there's only a handful of ideal
competitive mindsets either intense
slanky smooth
happy aggressive there's only a couple
of them that people talk about and then
they'll put their own language around it
okay
and so when i tie my shoes now i'm going
to like first trigger let's say and you
want the athlete or performer to create
these on their own
when i tie my shoes
what do i say to myself
when i put on my in my mouth guard what
do i say to myself when i put my helmet
on what do i say to myself as i walk
through the last threshold what do i say
to myself what do i do to get me closer
to that ideal competitive mindset so
that's what a pre-performance routine is
and
i think early on it's a really great
strategy
and i think it's really cool and you
might not ever believe it
but you're taking particular moments in
time to activate great thinking and
great body posture what about individual
versus team
is it is it just is team simply
individual multiplied by
x number of team members or is there a
difference
it's like a
one plus two equals something different
yeah you know and so
yeah it's not one one one one it's um
there's an in ecosystem there's a
culture that
is really important that allows people
the space or the pressure if you will to
figure out their potential to figure out
how to do something really well and i've
learned so much from coach carroll of
the seattle seahawks about culture about
creating a culture that gives people the
space
to be the very best they can be so you
mentioned uh pete carroll let's let's
talk about that for a second so in terms
of culture
on a team what are some of the
rules or ingredients or
that he's put in place to
help with culture it begins with the
relationship
first with himself and then with the men
and women inside of the organization
it's a relationship-based organization
the seattle seahawks what we do is we we
do football
but
like
said company produces a product or said
company produces a service we produce
football but we are relationship-based
organization is how we think about it
coach carolyn and myself and the
organization when i've looked at coaches
in any given sport
uh there very often
are certain behaviors or attitudes
actions that they just do not permit
is there anything on that list for this
yellow seahawks yeah um there's three
rules in the organization
what are they you want one of them yeah
all three
it's really making me work for it's like
willy wonka what is it my ears
i'm just kidding so be early
always always sorry always protect your
team
rule number one
rule number two no whining no
complaining no excuses
number three be early
pretty simple pretty simple simple
little rules always protect your team
have people's back
it's not about you being great it's
about figuring out who another person is
and celebrate them
always protect each other whether you're
in the gear or out of the gear where
you're in the club or we're in the
living room take care of each other and
we're going to create an ecosystem
that's trying to do that the best we
possibly can it's hard
you'd be surprised that maybe you
wouldn't be it's hard to do that because
people what happens under duress is they
want to take care of themselves or to
take care of them and their buddy no
protect all of us
and so that's a really powerful thought
and then underneath like no whining no
complaining no excuses like
own it own your stuff now
oh it is you and your responsibility
to bring the very best to compete to be
the very best so own your stuff and he's
great how he he plays with these two
those two rules and the third is be
early and what's underneath be early
it's not beyond time yeah it's be early
demonstrate that you care about the
other people that are part of the system
by organizing your life
by having respect that they're going to
be here too because if people are
waiting on you you're slow down the
whole system
so be early you know and so those are
very three basic rules and i'd say if
there's an unwritten rule it's the word
we talk about a lot it's love
and i've learned so much from the
athletes over the last couple years
through success
that public success that we've seen and
and winning super bowls not and not
winning super bowls and i've learned so
much from them about
uh love
and it's been wonderful
i know what you want to ask right now
what i want to ask yeah you want to ask
about what was it like to win a super
bowl what was it like to not win a super
bowl i i i tell you what what i what i'm
going to focus on first is
the loss tell me about
tell me about the loss we've had the
highlight we've had the highlight reel
so far let's talk about the loss yeah
okay the loss
um
what do you want to know about the loss
there's a lot to talk about yeah there's
a lot there's a lot too so this is super
bowl what is it 49
i want to know
the the
lead up to it so in that game if you
felt for instance if you felt like you
guys had done the best job possible in
preparation
and then the reaction from yourself and
uh the team when
you guys lost sure
what what a wild event the super bowl is
like it is media and um glitz and glam
and the whole thing is just like
amplified you know the nfl does a great
job of creating a wonderful event of the
super bowl
and
coach carroll and the coaching staff
are relentless relentless
and very thoughtful on the first day of
practice this is a championship practice
the first preseason game a lot of people
think preseason games are throwaway
games this is a championship opportunity
the third game of the season this is a
championship game
the next practice every practice is a
championship opportunity for practice we
get to the super bowl we're prepared
so the first super bowl
when you when you when you do a post
analysis the other team denver broncos
the other team were talking in media
about this is the biggest game of life
this is a this is a self-defining this
is it this is the this is the moment
it's the biggest game that we're gonna
ever play in and we're gonna we're gonna
do it
in the seahawks
this is another championship opportunity
this is what we do so we really see it
as
this is the opportunity that we're
prepared for it's not
i say there's no such thing as a big
game
there's no such thing as a big practice
no
no such thing as a big play
there's just this moment
coach carroll says
every game is big every practice is huge
every play is important and so let's
maximize it now in this moment
we get to the same exact place
and so it's a relentless training to be
as president as you possibly can and
never let that
influence this
that it comes from within and that's
dictating your your experience and
environment rather than being dictated
to
and so um
so i need to share that with you because
the win that's idyllic and it happens
all the time it's theoretical but and
it's applied the win it's easy to win
the loss in the way that the loss was
experienced in the second super bowl was
dramatic coach carroll did
two amazing things that i think are the
demonstration of a philosophy at work
so right after that happened
he's on the sidelines i didn't see this
but i saw the tape afterwards he's on
the sidelines and he just he watches the
play happen he's in it
and then the play unfolded where the the
ball was intercepted and he dropped his
head
it's about two second beat and then his
head comes back up
and when his head comes back up the
thought
i hope he's okay with me sharing it
because it's beautiful the thought that
he had was i got to be there for my guys
oh
just
that's what that's what it is
when you care so much you don't get
overwhelmed by your pain you feel it
but then
i got to be there for my men
i'm not a football guy i know very
little about it i can enjoy watching it
i enjoy super bowl parties
i enjoy highlight reels i can recognize
a hit that i wouldn't want to take
but the seahawks actually came onto my
radar about let's say a year ago when i
read a sports illustrated piece
about a book on stoicism the obstacle is
the way that it sort of
somehow found its way into the ranks of
the nfl including the seahawks yes and
i read this with great interest
you mentioned seneca i'm a huge fan of
seneca marcus aurelius it's one of the
philosophical schools i pay a lot of
attention to
and
when you think of not overreacting to
factors outside of your control or
emotionally overreacting to situations
it seems that you have to have
developed a certain degree of awareness
so what i wanted to ask you uh because
this has sort of come up indirectly a
few times is mindfulness what role does
that play in your world
so
a center you know it's a centerpiece for
sure mindfulness the ability
to be here now a particular way of
focusing on what's happening within
and outside of oneself at any given
moment like without it i'm not sure
i'm not sure how we can become
everything that we want to become i'm
not sure how we explore the depth of the
human experience without being aware
and so mindfulness is um
yeah it's a it is a center pillar it's a
day in and day out practice
and as often as i can talk about it i
love to and so um
you know it was
i think it was 19 uh 2000
2001 when i first began to understand
what it was really about from a mentor
that shared it with me
and it's just a
invisible process of becoming more aware
and for those people who are wondering
like i did for a very long time i went
out and in a very hap not haphazard
fashion it's scatter shot fashion
bought every book i could find on
meditation mindfulness and i came out of
it and i was like i am more confused now
yeah than i was when i started yeah
and uh
do you have any recommendations for
people who would like to develop that
type of awareness how they can either
start practicing or
resources or guidelines or anything that
you could suggest there are more and
more available resources for people that
want to go
read about it
or watch a video about it but that's not
how that's not how it works so the
the thought is to do it
is to
sit or stand or lay down or wherever
it's comfortable for you in a particular
moment and pay attention to one breath
at a time and start over and over and
over and over again
and
so it's the practice of it that is the
work and so i don't think you need to
read about it okay i would say start
first and mechanically just begin
with paying attention to your breathing
and then when your mind wanders which it
will like the natural state of mind is
like a drunk monkey and it wanders and i
don't know if yours is double-fisted
maybe i don't know what kind of show is
this
so drunk monkeys will get wild right
certainly so so so like all of us were
burdened and amused by the drunk monkey
and so getting having a relationship
with it and
bringing it back come on back to right
now
that's that's the work and so you don't
practice it
you don't get good at it
are there any uh you know can i finish
uh
yeah i i i want to make sure we don't
stop there because the real purpose of
mindfulness work is insight and wisdom
and so without without awareness
i'm not sure how to
help myself or another person reveal the
wisdom and insight within so
that's the real essence of it like it's
a deep process and if we only stopped
with awareness we'd be butchering an
ancient tradition that modern science is
finding to be incredible for change and
growth so i want to make sure that both
of those bookends are included no for
sure i mean it seems to me as someone
who's only
meditated consistently and i'm not
saying it's the same as mindfulness or
different ways to go about it but
for the last i want to say two to three
years i mean pretty recent uh as a
percentage of my lifetime
it seems like the awareness is putting
on the prescriptive glasses
that brings things into clarity but then
you also have to look at the right
things if you're just like reading
people magazine all day every day no
offense people magazine i still love you
but
you you also have to focus that clarity
on
the right areas uh
personally and then i would add to
listen as well yeah right a big part of
it um especially in modern times it's
hard to listen you know because there's
so much external stimulation and stuff
coming in from all over the globe you
know and we have it in our palm of our
hand so spending that time to integrate
literally integrate our senses you know
from what's happening within and what's
happening in the environment and just
listen
and that
the journey home there is
daunting
uh do you have any suggestions for
people who have kind of wobbled
trying this in the past so you can do a
coach you can do a digital coach which
is what an app is
um you could read about it sure and you
can also sit and pay attention to one
breath at a time and
so there's lots of ways to begin
it's the beginning the the process of
mindfulness is beginning a thousand
times
you know and over and over again it's
the process of
starting over so
if you just kind of
it's hard it really is hard to sell this
i think the people
i don't think it's impossible to sell it
because not until you understand it
and feel it
and not until you're around people that
are so grounded and so aware and so
switched on and
are able to adjust eloquently to
whatever environment do you go i want
some of that what is that
so that is
i think building a community of people
that are switched on in that way
you just want it and you know
we have such an engaged
incredible audience this evening let's
go to some audience questions
all right uh
this first question is from robert
mcbride
robert
when do you know
or how do you know when to draw the line
these are dangerous activities in some
cases that can and often do result in
injury or death
i think about that question a lot and
that's the thing that keeps me up
it really keeps me up at night
and so
here's my thoughts around it is um i
remember the first time i presented at a
conference
about some work i was doing in the in
the fight game there was a group of
psychologists in the back and they were
saying how are you doing this
and they were they were pissed like how
are you helping other people damage each
other
you know and so
that's when i that's when it really hit
me
that
they are grown adults that have
a real thing that they want to do that
is very meaningful to them
and i might i just might be able to help
them unlock some ways of thinking and
being
that will create safety for them when
they're in harm's way what was an
opportunity or a situation as you are
becoming better known
uh
that made you
whether it's nervous or just put you on
the spot in an emotional sense
well i'll tell you the one that i was um
luke akins who jumped out of an airplane
at 25 000 feet first person to do so
without a parachute
into a net that he designed and rigged
with a team of engineers
the consequences it's a binary outcome
he lives or he dies
and
you've got to be all in you have to love
deeply
because you don't know the next time
you'll see him you have to care deeply
and be fully present
and you got to get some stuff right you
really have to get some stuff right
because if i'm arming him with the wrong
strategy or approach on how to be fully
present
that could be really dangerous for him
and i feel privileged
i feel privileged to be
that intimate with people that are that
skilled and that open to growth and that
have
said publicly sometimes said i want to
learn more
i don't have all the answers and i need
it to be successful who better for me
who better than to learn from people
that are chipping in and pushing the
frontier
and
for me when the consequences are real
i'm way more interested because there's
so much more to learn i think well not
only real but clear right i mean you can
you can measure yeah for sure you know
and that's what i was most attracted to
are those environments where
consequences were on the line and many
consequences in sport are like money or
fame you know future contracts or
twisted ankles or reputation you know
something along those lines for most
stick and ball sports
um the off access sports where people
are in the rugged back countries doing
things that have never been done before
you know those those
point zero zero zero five percent of
people like the fractional frontier
explorers are such rare people we need
them
we need to understand them because
they're doing the things that you and i
are not doing or maybe even capable of
doing so they teach us about the
frontier when they come back and live
this question is from jeffrey n where
are you jeffrey n
all right and here's the question what
is something everyone should do on an
everyday basis
that's it
deeply
good advice
is there any practice that you have in
your life for ensuring that that is the
case
yeah it's
practicing openness practicing
vulnerability if you will practicing
saying the difficult things that are
difficult to say
and so love is an action it requires
doing loving things and one of the most
important things we can do
is um be present with people that's a
loving act you know
we're doing it right now
it was like a lady in the [ __ ] moment
you see that like you're missing the
spaghetti though
so
so that
that that's that's the practice like can
you be present with another person then
can you say the difficult things it's
hard to look away right now and then can
can you like can you be there when they
want to do the same thing a question
from
michael charles i suppose this is how
this is said from facebook
what is the first step from coming back
from massive failure
massive failure
i guess we'd have to operationalize what
massive failure is so i i like i i don't
really think about it in those terms
let's say the players after the super
bowl loss
so what do you do after what is the
process that's right
the value of front loading a philosophy
i can't say enough about it
because it becomes something it becomes
a compass and so this pain that one is
feeling is measured against the compass
it's measured against the tent pole so
front loading is a really important
process if you don't have that in place
it's really hard so they already have
the coping software it's pre-installed
and it still took a long time you know
so
i'd say uh if we think about massive
failure again the way i think about
failure is just playing it safe and
small and not going for it when you know
you have more to give
um
is to feel the pain that's the first
right like feel that pain and don't try
to lock it out no don't try to push it
away
feel it the only reason i don't have any
science around this other than my
experiences the only reason people
change is because of pain
so the worst thing a worst thing a
friend could do or a psychologist could
do or coach could do is take away pain
because pain is the impetus to be able
to say i'm done i'm not doing this
anymore this question is from zach d
zach d where are you
all right question is you have a lot of
advice for top performers in high stakes
scenarios what would your advice be to
the everyday person working in nine to
five jobs
saying it's uh same stuff first order
business is
good question i
tend not to think about advice giving
very much or or at all
because i don't i don't know
the path that people have walked and so
i need to learn a lot and in that in
those questions in that relationship
building so much is learned from both
people so there's a lot revealed in just
the beginnings of that
so if i kind of put that into a way that
you could maybe or we could
operationalize that is like be in
relationships where people really
genuinely care
like find those relationships where they
really want to see you do well and so
you'll have conversations and
stimulating uh questions and responses
that get to the center of stuff so that
would be the first thing i would suggest
the second is from the craft standpoint
of the skills that i've come to learn
from science and people in the in the
rugged environments is being present is
very very important like it's like
almost mission critical
and so figuring out a way for you or us
to be more present in our lives is
foundational
and mindfulness would be one of the
great practices another way for
enhancing
the ability to be present is
conversation
so there's three ways that i like to
think about the process of awareness and
insight is great conversations writing
and then mindfulness which is listening
and then the third would be
know who you are and
let it rip
like flat out let it rip nine to five
what does that mean it's like you've got
you've got a life that you're living and
it's now and there's nowhere other than
now so know who you are and never let
refuse to
let somebody or an environment dictate
your experience in life and when you do
have those moments
and i i say that to him because i lived
it for so long and it's so painful it's
so painful too
to be consumed with what others think so
i would say that those are the three and
then so how do you do that get after it
every day
get after it and put yourself in these
really uncomfortable emotionally
uncomfortable situations where you can
feel
so that you can adjust this next
question is from connor mccloskey
where's connor where's connor connor's
right there you mentioned studying
seneca in college or at least reading
seneca how much of a role does stoicism
play in your life
good question
stoicism as an idea like the center of
it and i'd love um some brushing up on
it from from you is like
control what you can
like just just pay attention to getting
that stuff right so if you think about
mastery and this is a
the thing that i'm most interested in as
a craft right like what is the process
of mastery and
what is it in particular i'll tell you
what it keeps coming up over and over
again whether it's seneca or the some of
the ancient traditions and the wise men
that are doing the thing today they are
relentlessly talking about listen i
don't have time for all that other noise
it's about i want to have great thoughts
great actions great effort great
attitude i want to control the stuff
that's in my control all that other
stuff i'm working to gate it out
and so on
so if you had the opportunity to put
a few words
short message on a gigantic billboard in
other words just get it out to the world
what would you put on the billboard
it's going to sound too campy i mean i
want to say something really clever and
smart or whatever that you know could i
don't know but it it i'd be pretty
freaking simple you know it would be
love
you know just freaking do that great you
know and so
and then i'd say like if there's
something something like
with a sharper edge to it you know not
that love is soft it's really hard to do
but if there's something with a sharper
edge i'd say that billboard would read
make make a decision
build capacity
and test yourself
you know i think it would be those three
things like and test yourself yep
and if you could make one request of
everybody
watching this just like a next step
a suggestion whatever it might be and
ask of the audience
what would it be
each one of us are on a unique journey
and that journey is
um not determined by
what you do but rather who you are so
the journey is a journey of
self-discovery and i would
want i would be wonderful if people
would embrace more people would embrace
a true authentic journey of
self-discovery
and then with that discovery to be able
to
share those insights and gifts with
others and so
that kind of relationship based
amplification of authenticity would be
like phenomenal if if more people could
go down that path
and then i'd add a layer on top of it
would say you know get in really rugged
and hostile environments and feel what
it feels like to be on the razor's edge
and be overwhelmed by it and then come
to love that razor's edge
and then the last would be
learn how to be here now
you know like learn how to work with
your own mind to be in the present
moment and increase the frequency of
being able to do that across many
different environments and i think if we
could get some sort of those threes
those three things right like test
yourself go on your authentic journey
and be here now like we'd be on some
cool stuff
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you